the triple lock is very important it's
something that
[Music]
is there in place to protect pensioner
incomes in the future
the government can give no guarantee on
it we give an absolute guarantee on it
that pensions will rise
by either two and a half percent or the
rising costs or the average rise of
earnings whichever is the highest
now that's something actually i
campaigned for from when i was first
elected to parliament in the 1980s and
i have no intention of abandoning those
commitments
either then or now now if you um look at
towards the future next couple of years
one of the things that's really going to
hit people who are really genuinely
struggling to get by
is this policy that the conservatives
have of freezing working age benefits
so just to really be clear are you
saying that you would end that freeze on
working age benefits
on working work related benefits what we
will do
is we've set aside a large sum of money
to deal with the anomalies that exist
in the system at the moment we've
dealing with the issue of the capability
for work tests which are extremely
unfair on those with disabilities
and we will also raise the living wage
to 10 pounds an hour because what i'm a
little bit confused about
is that you say that there's this big
pot money set aside um
and in your manifesto you say 2 billion
pounds a year is being spent on
things around universal credit so where
is the
3 billion a year that the ifs say would
be needed
to end the freeze on those benefits
the issue about universal credit is that
it includes
housing costs and housing costs are
actually the biggest part of it in some
parts
of the country and so we need to look at
that and see if they can't in the longer
term be a separation
of them so would you end the freeze i'm
just kind of
yes the free the freeze would be ended
because it's very very
unfair on those people in receipt of
those
those benefits so where is the money
coming from because it's not in your
manifesto we've set aside the sum we've
mentioned with that is a set aside as a
start and we'll obviously review it as
time goes on
okay um i'm just um keen to get a bit
more detail on your
priorities because it does feel as
though on benefits this is where
people who are really struggling the
people that you clearly want to help
are going to be hit um just one pound
and 10 in your manifesto
is being spent on welfare and yet if you
look at some of your other big spending
commitments things like
11 billion pounds scrapping tuition fees
a billion pounds free school meals
6 billion pounds on the triple lock i
mean a lot of those can be seen as
handouts to the middle classes people
who don't necessarily
need it preschool meals is a
ensuring every child gets a decent free
school meal
and they eat it together and that's
important
improving housing is a very big part of
it improving the living wage is a very
big part of it
and so it will help to eliminate poverty
within our society there are also
those at the far end of the scale who've
got no house to live in we will
eliminate homelessness as well because
it does feel so
on the idea of universal benefits
helping everyone to have free school
meals sounds great in theory but when
there's limited money
shouldn't you be focusing more on people
on the bottom end of the scale people
who are on benefits
we're focusing on improving the lot
of the poorest and worst off in society
i've mentioned the point about free
school meals
i mentioned the point about housing i
mentioned the point about pensions i
mentioned the point
about living wage i've also said we'll
bring back the educational maintenance
allowance which will be helped to
encourage young people to stay on at
school and that we will
make sure there is an opportunity for
all those that want to and are capable
of getting in
to go to university without mounting up
debts of 50 000 pounds
now another area where i just want to
get a bit more clarity about your
priorities is brexit and immigration so
your manifesto says
freedom of movement will end when we
leave the european union
and labor will develop and implement
fair immigration rules
so just be really clear does that mean
you want to see more or less
immigration freedom of movement
obviously
ends when you leave the european union
because it's conditional uh condition of
the membership of the european union
we will then have an important single
market not necessarily
immigration policy that is based on
fair migration that the needs of our
society our economy and the rights of
family reunion
i think that has to be the right way of
looking at it but we also have to
look at the immigration debate
additionally in terms of eu nationals
that arrest in britain and we will make
sure they're able to remain in britain
and also recognize the enormous
contribution made by those that have
come to this country in our national
health service education
and transport industries because without
them we'd have
much worse services than we have at the
present time i'm still not quite clear
if you want immigration to go up or down
i want there to be fair immigration
based on the needs of our society
and that is a proper way of approaching
it
the concern is well it's not what you
ask but it's what it's what the
conservatives have
offered in the last three elections last
two elections plus this one they're
going to bring it down
they didn't and they couldn't and i'm
saying that will be
fair migration based on the needs of the
society but there will also not be
the undercutting of working arrangements
in this country by the bringing in
of whole workforces to work for very low
wages
to destroy working conditions in the
society so there will be an end to those
agencies that try and recruit workforces
overseas so you won't say if you want it
to go up or down
i want us to have a society that works
and a balance that works and i
i cannot get into numbers games because
i don't think it works
it's just a direction of travel i'm not
asking for you know a target or a limit
i'm just saying would you like it to go
up or down
what i want is a society that works and
what i want is fair migration i will
probably be lower but i don't i won't i
don't want to start making predictions
on that because the issue has to be
the needs of our economy if we can't
recruit the nurses we need and we
ask nurses to come and work here from
abroad if we can't recruit the engineers
because the conservative government
hasn't invested in training for so long
then we have to do something about it
we're in a world where a lot of people
move around
they're also one and a half two million
people
from british people living all across
europe i want them to have rights of
residents just as much as they want eu
nationals in this country
to have permanent rights of residence
because the reason that i'm
compressing you on this is because
you're saying that you want freedom of
movement to end which effectively means
that uk
has to come out of the single market i
understand why theresa may wants to do
that because she wants to bring
immigration down but if you don't
necessarily want to bring immigration
down
then why on earth do you want free me
we're leaving the european union
therefore that principle uh is is
changed at that you can have a norway
model couldn't you you could have you
know
accept free movement of people we will
negotiate the principle being
tariff-free access to the european
market because that is essential
to maintain manufacturing industry and
service industry jobs in britain
absolutely you've given us a whole
membership because of free movement of
people and yet you don't
really care it seems if immigration
comes up or down what i care about
is this country having a good trading
relationship with europe and maintaining
our manufacturing industry jobs and our
opportunities for trade for the future
with the european union that requires
a labor government that's going to
invest in the economy rather than a
government that's going to continue the
policy
of tax handouts for the top end and tax
handouts to big corporations
i'm interested in the kind of issues of
your sort of character your personality
because you're asking people to
vote for you to be the next prime
minister of the uk so i just want to
show you this
editorial now this is taken from the
labor briefing
magazine back in december 1984
were you general secretary of the
editorial board at that time when that
was published
i wasn't even a member of the editorial
board you weren't a member of the
editorial board because
according to parliamentary profiles by
andrew roth authoritative
andrew roth has a wonderful reputation
for having the most inaccurate
parliamentary profiles
known to anyone so you were not a member
of the editorial board of that magazine
in december 1984 categorically not
i read the magazine i wrote for the
magazine there was not a member of the
editorial report okay
what it says um in the article just in
the wake of the brighton bombing an
attack
by the ira of course intended to kill
margaret thatcher which killed five
people
the british only sit up and take notice
when they are bombed
into it how does that make you feel
knowing you wrote for that magazine
i didn't agree with it i don't agree
with that position
i've always wanted there to be peace in
ireland
i've always wanted there to be an accord
and eventually
in 1994 a um ceasefire was agreed that
one
disappeared but second ceasefire came in
1997.
i've always wanted there to be peace and
i really welcome the good friday
agreement and all the achievements that
it's made since then so why did you
continue to write for that magazine then
i wrote for the magazine on many issues
because it's magazine that reaches a
number of people within the labour party
in the labour movement
there are many things in many papers and
many magazines with which i profoundly
disagree does that mean i don't engage
there are programs on your station that
i don't really agree with you probably
don't agree with them either
isn't that what um open debate and
journalism is about
sometimes listening to people that you
don't agree with does he good
now your associations
during the 1980s which i accepted a long
time ago
um have clearly come under scrutiny
recently
and time and time again it does appear
as though you backed people who
opposed the british forces you were
arrested a demonstration
in support of an ira terrorist in 1986
you were regular at ira
linked troops out rallies you didn't
support the
sdlp who are trying to pursue a united
island through peaceful means
so how can you say that you were trying
to talk to all sides of the agreement
when it does appear as though
there is one clear side that you were
backing and that is
hardline republicans i worked with
colleagues in parliament in the sdlp and
the labour party
i visited northern ireland on a number
of occasions
i met people from right across the
spectrum i went on delegations of the
northern ireland committee of the
parliamentary labour party
i represent a constituency which has a
very large number of
irish people living in it and
i pointed out that the prevention of
terrorism act
was counterproductive and was
criminalizing large numbers of holy
innocent irish people
i took up the cause of the guilford iv
and birmingham six who were
grotesquely misjudged by british courts
and eventually were freed
on the decision of the high court in
britain and i wanted to bring about
peace in ireland you have to talk to
people with whom you don't agree
and i did if you have to talk to people
with whom you don't agree can you talk
of any extremist loyalists then who knew
i met i met a numbers numbers of uh
loyalists in
visits to stormont and other places and
uh discussions with
them of uh their views on how things
come about because fundamentally the
piece in ireland came about because
of a preparedness to talk because of
hume adams accord
because of what happened after that with
the good friday agreement
so can you condemn unequivocally the ira
look bombing is wrong of course all
bombing is wrong and of course i can do
it
but you can't having all bombings can
you condemn the ira or without
equating it too no i think what you have
to say is all bombing
has to be condemned and you have to
bring about a peace process
listen
in the 1980s britain was looking for a
military solution in ireland
it clearly was never going to work ask
anyone in the british army
at that time and therefore you have to
seek
a peace process you condemn the violence
of those
that laid bombs that killed large
numbers of innocent people and i do
so can you condemn their the ira i've
just condemned
all those responsible
all those on both sides but would can
you condemn the ira without equating
the ira he's responsible for 60 at the
death during the troubles with the
british
security services who were responsible
and there were lawless bombs as well
which you haven't mentioned yeah 30
do a loyalist bomb as well i condemn all
the bombing by both the lawyers and the
republicans can you just say you but
you're welcome
wait a minute i don't know quite what
your point you're trying to make here
those of us that wanted peace in ireland
worked very hard for it
that labour government in 1997 worked
very effectively
to achieve that it was the thatcher
government that was
going in after the collapse of sunnydale
that went very much in the direction of
a military solution which clearly didn't
work hence we eventually got
the agreements and the ceasefire which
was painstaking and got there but
the fundamentals of the
accord are actually that you recognize
the traditions
all the historical traditions of ireland
both the
unionist and the nationalist traditions
so you don't believe you did anything
wrong and that you have nothing to
apologize for
i represent a constituency that how many
people have been criminalized under the
pta
i represented people who had been
wrongly put in prison
for a very long time for crimes they did
not commit
i recognize that you had to bring about
a peace process in ireland
i did my best to assist in that process
and that is the way you bring about
peace anywhere around the world
and later on after the good friday
agreement
the northern ireland process became a
bit of a model around the world
martin mcginnis traveled a great deal as
did those from the unionist side as well
to other parts of the world to help try
and promote
that kind of peace dialogue so john
mcdonnell has apologized for some of the
comments you made you don't believe you
have anything to apologize for in any of
the associations or the decisions
i've told you what my principles behind
it were you very well aware of what i
was doing during that period
and i think we've achieved a much better
place in ireland
and a lot of people made a lot of
contributions to that
unionists republicans
mps from all parties in britain
political parties of all shapes
in stormont made a contribution to that
so northern ireland
and indeed the whole of the island of
ireland is in a much better place as a
result of it the troubles were a
terrible period
yeah i think no one would certainly
disagree with you uh on that point and
i've talked to people in the army
soldiers who were there at the time they
would agree as well
is there an issue where if you look
through your manifesto
there are clearly policies in there that
are very popular policies that you've
been
fighting for domestic policies since
before i was born
are you worried that your position on
things like national security and
foreign affairs
is going to mean that millions of people
can't vote for your popular domestic
policies as a result
no because our position is this we want
social justice in britain
we want security around the world
obviously
therefore the issues that are not being
addressed such as the cyber security
attacks on this country
last week have to be addressed and we
will through a strategic defense review
look at those issues and make sure that
we are properly prepared for what is
the latest modern form of warfare but
it's also
about security in our own society
real security which is people having
somewhere decent to live
some hope of getting a decent job and
some hope that they will have
a health and education services there
for them at all times security comes in
lots of forms
are you going to win then the election
it's going very well large numbers of
people
are flocking to join the labour party
and join in our campaigns
and the manifesto is very very popular
because it's serious
it's prepared it's costed 95 percent of
the population will not pay any more for
it
and indeed those are 90 000 a year will
only pay 500 pounds more and it'll be
graded beyond that
in order to pay for decent education
decent
health service and proper respect for
the older population
by protecting their pensions mccluskey
suggested it would be a
successful campaign if you won 200 seats
do you agree with that
lee mccluskey was thinking out loud i
believe i haven't spoken to him before
or since then
i obviously know him but haven't spoken
to him very recently
we're campaigning to win this election
we
are mobilizing a lot of people to win
this election large numbers of people
who never voted before
are registering to vote and you know
what they're having a conversation
about the kind of society we are and the
kind of direction in which we go
i think it's about time we had that
conversation and i'm very happy to be
part of it and i'm enjoying it
jeremy corbyn thank you very much thank
you